here at cbs news
we are committed to stopping the stigma
surrounding mental health so we can take
the shame
and the blame out of discussing mental
illness
former first lady michelle obama
revealed she is quote dealing with some
form of
low-grade depression she discussed her
mental health in the newest episode of
her podcast yesterday and pointed to the
pandemic
and racial tensions across the country
i'd be remiss to say that part of this
depression
is also a result of what we're seeing in
terms of
the protests the continued racial unrest
that has plagued this country since its
birth
i have to say that waking up to the news
waking up to how this administration has
or has not responded waking up
to yet another story of a black man
or a black person somehow being
dehumanized
or hurt or killed or falsely accused of
something
it is exhausting and and it
it has led to a weight that i haven't
felt
in my life in a while
to help manage her depression michelle
obama says she's been keeping a regular
routine
reaching out to friends and family and
exercising
guys leave it to the former first lady
to encapsulate how
so many of us are feeling and she says
that even when she experiences these
emotional highs and lows she tries not
to be so hard on herself if
she's not feeling the treadmill on that
one particular day she's going to give
herself a break
spend more time with their family they
play games they play puzzles i think
it's a good way to think about it
yeah i think just talking about it is
what it comes down to in breaking the
stigma letting people know we all
sort of struggle at some point or
another and sometimes more than others
because not easy to talk about for
anyone if you or someone you know is
seeking mental health resources you can
call the national alliance on mental
illness the helpline at 1-800-950-6264
or in a crisis text
7417